spending just a few days and weeks with
these monkeys you start to see their
individual personalities start to emerge
some of them are chatty some of them are
kind of quiets others are just plain old
mean and while it's interesting to watch
this just from a human observer
perspective this is also really valuable
information for scientists by tracking
individuals from dawn until dusk every
day we can take this kind of individual
level information and learn about their
structure of their society like who's
related to whom who's higher-ranking or
lower-ranking or bits about you know if
they're stressed out and what that means
for their internal state unfortunately
you can't embarrass lis go up to a
monkey and ask for a reminder of what
its name is if you forget so we invest a
lot of our time in the field just trying
to learn their faces and this involves
binocular standing really close to
something and just staring at it for
some monkeys this is not that hard at
all this guy right here is a face that
only a mother monkey could love and
hopefully it doesn't reappear in your
dreams a little bit later tonight this
one you could learn in five seconds
other animals you don't have to rely on
faces to panda here on the left has half
a tail you can tell her from you know 20
30 meters away but for the majority of
them it comes down to looking at little
ridges in their face little moles they
might have or old scars from fights so
we try to get as much of this into our
own mental banks as we can but we do
rely on our notes and fortunately Vivek
and I are both world-class Natural
History illustrators and we've filled up
our notebooks with all sorts of
illustrations like this I think this is
davecs Mona Lisa here but jokes aside
this is a really valuable tool to kind
of remember the little landmarks on a
monkey's face and so we were the first
kind of cohort of camp managers at guava
so not only did we have to learn monkeys
that had been identified by Peter and
Nia but we also identified a bunch of
new ones as well and on some days it was
really exciting you see a female who's
recognizable
and you know you might want to name her
and this is what happened with a
juvenile I think back early when we were
there I was just standing there and
Vivek ran up really excitedly Jeff I
have a new mochi for us oh really
that's very exciting vivec have you
thought of a name yet
I think I want to name it a new show a
new show what does that mean well it's
my sister's name and I I think she'll
hate it
perfect it's excited normally we you
know deliberate a long time back and
forth because these names are in the
record but that one was a pretty pretty
easy call and it's been fun to track a
new show over the years I know she was a
juvenile when we first identified her
and now you know she's come into her own
she has offspring and some of the latest
news is that Anusha has a new male which
is very exciting
but mothers have really intimate
relationships with their infants they
invest a great deal of time with them on
caring for them while they still have to
go about their daily duties so you'll
see a mother holding an infant like this
with one hand while she's grabbing grass
with the other one it's always amusing
when she kind of you know craps his
wires a little bit and whacking her
infant in the head while she's putting
grass into her mouth but this
relationship between mother and infant
can last years as they grow up a bit
more though give them rides when they're
tired
gelatos can walk several kilometers a
day in search of just the right grass
meals and they'll help them jump across
little obstacles like this and when the
kids need help they'll let them know
they'll stand there screaming like and
then it annoys the mom just enough swill
throw them on the back and take them to
the other side but it's not only
behavior that we focus on oh we're out
there knowing individuals can unlock all
sorts of other information sources as
well you can tell the VEX really excited
about this one
I think he gave a little teaser of it
earlier and this is processing monkey
fecal sample and when a monkey poops it
gives you all sorts of information it
tells you what it's been eating how well
it's been digesting that and all their
information about its internal state you
can extract hormones from poop as well
so what we do is we follow know one end
of the
Jules around and then try to guess when
they're going to poop and Vivek and I
are both pretty competitive guys so this
is a nice way to pass those long endless
stays in the field you know who can end
up with the most fecal samples in the
morning like who can have this morning I
haven't talked about this publicly
before but um I think the VEX a little
bit better at this than I am
unfortunately so congratulations thank
you we can also look at disease in fecal
samples because disease is in important
parts of the geladas ecology about 30%
of adults in the population at glossa
have parasitic swellings of tapeworms
from the genus tinea and you can see the
swelling here on the head of this monkey
but they can be found anywhere on the
body at some point the swelling's will
continue to expand and occasionally
rupture and it's a way that the monkeys
can get infected and then lead to
mortality another kind of outlet of
competition for via can die related to
disease in us I lost about 30 pounds of
body weight while I was in guava the
first year and that had to do with a
variety of kind of bacterial and viral
issues but we had this contest running
for some reason that we want to know who
could go the longest without a shower so
we went for I think two months and then
a couple days and I was supposed to go
back to the capital right before the VEX
so I broke I was like alright fine this
one's yours but this sort of idiotic
competition led to other problems as
well I think for both of us the hands
the flesh on our hand started rotting
off and falling off in big sloths and we
didn't really know what it was so we
wrote to some tropical disease
specialists and they didn't know what it
was either
so we dumped some balsamic vinegar on it
and then we put gloves on and it went
away after a couple months okay well so
you just heard about how Jeff and I can
get pretty competitive but that's mostly
in very trivial context
we had too much time on our hands but
male-male competition in geladas is
actually no laughing matter because it
has profound life-and-death consequences
I mentioned earlier how each male gelada
is associated with a group of females
his harem now this kind of demographic
imbalance creates a problem because it
means there's this pool of males that
aren't getting mating opportunities so
there's a huge amount of competition for
these top spots and evolution has
basically shaped gelada males to reflect
this legacy of competition you can see
that in this male here first of all he's
big and imposing male geladas are about
twice the size of the females if you're
going to be fighting all the time it
really it really helps to be big and
they're made even their mates look even
larger by this billowing cape that you
see right here the secondary sexual
characteristics this makes them look
more imposing and these aggressive
interactions we also go back to that the
chest patch so he is a very red
bleeding-heart there and what that
indicates is that testosterone is
coursing through his veins he's ready to
fight and put it all out there what's
truly spectacular though are the canines
gelada canine teeth are one of the
largest among any primates relative to
body size and during the day when we're
out with the animals we can hear them
grinding their teeth against each other
they're grinding that canine against the
bottom row sharpening it for a
subsequent conflict
now when fights erupt they can be pretty
crazy to watch and sometimes we even get
hit by monkeys that run into us but they
can go on for hours if not days and
eventually there's going to be a winner
so we observed the day's long
interaction in 2011 where at the end of
it we heard a bone crunching sound and
one male limped away totally bloody he
disappeared after a few hours and and we
never saw him again
all the geladas become really really
upset during
these takeover events but it's the adult
females in the group where there's a
takeover attempts that stand to lose the
most that's because in gelada is because
of the social system they have you see a
very disturbing distasteful behavior
this is infanticide the killing of
infants the way this works is the male's
the new males will grab an infant off
the mother's back and it will turn these
canines onto the baby why are they doing
this they're doing this because that
baby isn't theirs and they want to have
their own chance of reproduction so by
killing this baby that belonged to
someone else they're able to stop the
mother from lactating and have her start
her cycle again so that he can then mate
with her so these males are advancing
their own reproductive interests at the
expense of the females as well as at the
expense of other males like the one you
see here terrified that his offspring is
about to get about to get killed now the
females in this story are actually not
passive players at all and it was
recently discovered that geladas have
evolved an amazing strategy to
counteract these infanticide old
tendencies of the males so this was
discovered by our colleagues at the
University of Michigan working at the
simians research site with geladas in
Ethiopia they discovered that in geladas
a phenomenon known as the Bruce effect
is operating what this means is that
when there's a takeover in a group the
females who are pregnant will
spontaneously terminate their
pregnancies pregnancy and having a baby
is really energetically costly if that
baby were to be born it would be bit
would be killed the day that it's born
so they cut their losses and terminate
the pregnancy they start cycling again
and can soon have a baby in the end they
end up losing little time overall in
their own reproductive careers so this
kind of drama it almost seems more
fitting for Game of Thrones but this is
daily life for gelato
this can be heavy stuff to watch
particularly when it's your job to just
take notes about it or gather pictures
of it but it's part of the job you sign
up for this when you engage in kind of a
long term field project like this and it
also comes with other aspects when
you're out in the field for months at a
time particularly in Alpine environments
you're exposed to some very extreme
weather they can be challenging as well
so as we kind of proceed through this
day in the life of a gelada in the early
afternoon it can turn from sunny to just
absolutely dreadful very quickly and
this has big impacts on our data
collection our ability to take
photographs and our ability to stay sane
which is going to be reflected shortly
[Music]
it's been raining about non-stop since
Platt 45 this morning
[Music]
[Applause]
as cliche what yeah I think we've spent
several Christmases at the Glossop but
it's always Christmas when there's hail
on the ground people ask me sometimes if
I'm afraid of the monkeys attacking me
or you know afraid of the animals kind
of turning on us out there but to be
totally straight a few it's the
lightning I am deeply deeply afraid of
lightning in Alpine environments and
rightfully so it's very dangerous so I
get kind of a chill seeing some of those
videos they're fun to like look back on
but I don't want to spend another rainy
season at the glossa
and to be fair the geladas probably
don't want to spend another rainy season
at the glossa either but they don't have
as much choice as I do it's a very
exposed place there's nowhere to hide so
they just have to you know sit out there
and take it like you're research
assistants sitting right there as well
and they'll bundle together and just
wait it out some days they won't even
come up from their cliff edges and you
know that can be difficult to find for
days or weeks at a time
but with these rainy periods which can
last for days or weeks or months there's
kind of a seasonal cycle to it the
Highlands transform they become very
lush on the guava that grass grows green
and tall and down on the farms the crops
start growing and the livestock start to
fatten up on the really nutritious grass
that exists down there there's more
livestock in Ethiopia than in any other
country yet it's rare to see any
livestock on the guava itself and this
is by design for centuries we're talking
hundreds of years here the local
community has limited access to the
guava except during an occasional time
of need every couple of years and what
this means is that they're trying to
protect their most precious resource on
the glossa and that's the grass the word
guava is derived from the Amharic word
for for stupid grass which you see
growing here
aside from being a potential buffer zone
for grazing animals and livestock the
grass itself is a very useful resource
for the local people they use it to
thatch the ruse of their houses they use
it to build ropes line their floors and
build brooms and many other tools as
well and for centuries enforcement of
this closure of the glossa from grazing
or for grass cutting was associated with
the Ethiopian Orthodox Church this is a
really important institution in
Highlands and it ties in with traditions
that's um go back you know more than
century's enforcement could be very
severe however many years ago if you
were caught illegally grazing your
cattle it would be killed on the spot if
you cut grass without permission your
house would be burned down in recent
years a more secular and less severe
version of this enforcement has emerged
and now it's being led by this man add
masu Gitana
who is a former soldier turned
conservationist he leads patrols of
local farmers from the community on the
glossa day and nights looking for
unwelcome Outsiders people that are
poaching its resources cutting its grass
cutting down its shrubs to make charcoal
and for centuries the fact that they
have been preserving this region to
protect his grass has had the unintended
consequence at least initially of
preserving its wildlife this is not the
case throughout many of the other parts
of the Ethiopian highlands where farming
in over grazing has led to erosion and
just the real change in the land cover
that you see this is outside of guava
and this is a photograph of Ryan Burke
another former camp manager from the
glossa gelato research project over the
past several years along with several of
his Ethiopian colleagues
they've been scouring the highlands
looking for information about geladas
sensing them and figuring out what their
distribution is and they've created this
map this is the most up-to-date
understanding that we have
gelada distribution there found only in
Ethiopia along these high-altitude ridge
lines associated with the Great Rift
Valley and the gorges that go inland
from it this is a much reduced range
from what people thought geladas existed
in based on some preliminary surveys
4050 years ago and right now Ryan and
his team are still working on these
surveys there's a couple areas left to
go but this is really rewriting what we
know about gelada distribution big wasa
is located right in the center and it
stands apart as I mentioned as the most
ecologically pristine elements where
geladas are found and with an
ecologically intact environment comes
other things in this case predators it's
very rare to see a predator out in the
daylight in the highlands this is only
one of a couple sightings I had of a
servo cat over my time there but there
are also hyenas and leopards and other
mammalian predators in this environment
despite the fact that you don't often
see predators they still have a massive
impact on the behavior of this species
geladas are always on edge and you'll
hear alarm calls coming up maybe several
times a day where geladas will stop what
they're doing and scan the environments
devoting all their attention to
assessing whether there's a threatened
area most of the time there are false
alarms but they have good reason to be
worried I had no idea that I was
standing just a couple meters away from
a serval that was hiding in this bush
and neither did the female who was
carrying this infant I was standing
there and I saw a flash of movement and
her geladas starting to scream I spun
around and kind of threw my camera up
and took this photograph a second later
the servo was gone buried in this st.
Johns wart thicket you can tell this
infants just a couple days old it still
has the umbilical cord attached and a
dried-out placenta onon the herd was
screaming and fled back towards their
sleeping cliffs followed by their mother
who was given her own mournful calls
even if geladas don't experience a
predation event just
predators often enough to send herd
fleeing back towards the cliffs
[Music]